J'AI UN PROBLÈÈÈÈÈÈÈÈÈÈÈÈME !!!
Depuis maintenant des dizaines d'années !!
Bon, deux dizaines d'années vu que j'ai 20 ans !
Ces jeux-vidéos...
[cri aigu]
Reprenons l'histoire depuis le début :
Lucas Hauchard et les jeux-vidéos c'est quoi ?
Lorsqu'il était petit, Lucas découvrit les jeux-vidéos grâce à son grand-frère Florent.
Il jouait à Tekken sur PS1, mais vu que le jeu était violent, leur maman adorée cachait le jeu pour les faire chier.
Plus tard, Lucas découvrit le site de jeu flash "AbsoluFlash", il y passa de nombreuses heures.
Il découvrit ensuite Counter Strike 1.6 puis Dofus qui lui prit une bonne partie de son existence.
ET LÀ, CERTAINS SE SOUVIENDRONS :
Ça, ça.
Comment c'est arrivé cette cicatrice ?
La belle cicatrice, là, là.
Vous savez sûrement !
Je jouais à Dofus, j'étais en plein combat.
Mais mon horaire de PC c'était de 18 heures à 19 heures.
Et mon frère c'était de 19 heures à 20 heures.
Il était 19h05 et mon frère me mettait la pression pour que je lui lâche le PC, ce qui est normal !
Mais je voulais terminer ce combat contre des prespics pour dropper ma coiffe du prespic. Puceau.
Et donc carotte 10 minutes sur le pc de mon frère celui-ci, fut pris de rage
et éteigna le pc de force et moi qu'est-ce-que je fais j'ai 12 ans j'ai le bibi qui commence à pousser.
*baaah* Aaaaaah
J'ai frappé dans un cadre et j'ai eu  20 points de suture.
Première fois de ma vie que je rage au
point de me blesser physiquement.
Des années plus tard blizzard sortit un
nouveau jeu vidéo qui révolutionna la vie de Squeezie.
Overwatch . Les amis au moment où je fais cette vidéo , on est lundi il est actuellement 13 heures 10
J'ai passé le pire week-end
jeux vidéo ludique de ma vie.
J'en ai les larmes au yeux quand j'en parle.
Pas encore mais ca va monter je le sais.
Bon vous connaissez forcement Overwatch de nom.
Mais je vais vous expliquer un p'tit peu  le système de classement.
En gros, dans Overwatch, tu peux faire des parties : classées.
Et selon ton niveau tu vas appartenir à une certaine catégorie.
Bronze, Argent, Or, Platine, Diamant, Maître, Grand Maître.
Mickalo il est là.
Moi j'suis là. Connard Mickalo Connard !
Donc t'es dans ta catégorie, tu joues, t'essais de passer dans la catégorie du d'ssus.
En gagnant le plus de parties possible.
Dès que t'en perds, tu perds des points
donc tu risques même de passer dans celle d'en dessous. Bref, c'est terrible !
Et au bout de 2 ou 3 mois, la saison se termine.
Cela veut dire que tous les rangs sont remis à zéros.
Y'a une courte pause d'une semaine ou deux.
Et une nouvelle saison commence.
Et là, c'est les games de placements.
Tu fais 10 parties, et faut en gagner le plus possible pour atterrir directement
dans l'une des catégories, celles que j'ai dis t'alheur là.
ça permet de départager les gens
dès le début de la saison si vous voulez.
En gros, le mec a perdu toutes ses games il se retrouve en Bronze.
Avec les autres mec qui ont perdu toutes leurs games qui ont donc le niveau des Bronzes.
Le mec qui a tout gagné se retrouve diamant ou maître et se retrouve avec les mecs qui ont tout gagné
Et qui se retrouve diamant/maître aussi.
Bref, voilà !
ça met les nuls avec les nuls, les forts avec les forts, et les normaux avec les normaux.
C'est là qu'un problème intervient. *rire*
Je fais mes games de placements,
Je tryhard au point de saigner du nez
en me mouchant vous entendez ?
Il me fallait un coton tige, pour me nettoyer le nez avant de dormir tellement j'avais saigné de rage.
Ouais dans les mangas ils saignent du nez quand ils voient des filles sexy.
Moi je saigne du nez quand je joue à un jeu vidéo.
Voilà.
Et quand je vois une fille sexy, je meurs.
Je fais ma première game de placement, et c'est une grosse défaite.
C'est la première y'en a 10.. Tranquille.
Et là j'avais jamais vécu ça avant, une série de victoire, mon gars.
Une série.. Squeezie ? Qui fait une série de victoire ?
J'ai eu plus de mal à faire cette série de victoire,
qu'à avoir 7 millions d'abonnés !
Ma deuxième game je la gagne, ma troisième game,
je la gagne, ma quatrième game je la gagne, la cinquième game j'fais une p'tite égalité
Voilà. 6ème game j'la gagne, 7ème game j'la gagne, 8ème game j'la gagne.
Et les deux dernières j'sais plus parce que j'étais tellement excité que ma mémoire elle s'est éteinte.
Je me dis donc que je vais atterrir dans la catégorie : Diamant.
Et l'avantage de la catégorie diamant,
quand tu atteins donc 3000 points.
C'est que si tu repasses en dessous des 3000,
tu restes Diamant.
Et à la fin de la saison, ton rang étant diamant tu gagneras beaucoup de points de côte.
Qui permettent d'acheter une armure d'or kikoolol qui brille de partout, flambant neuve.
*Son étrange mêlé de joie et d'extase*
Oh Zarya t'as le corps de Tibo Inshape mais j'taime.
Accrochez vous bien à vos testicules, je pop, avec une cote de 2988 à 12 points du diamant.
Sachant que quand tu gagnes une game, après tes games de placement, tu gagnes 40 points de cotes.
Autant te dire que j'étais à un poil de cul du diamant.
Et là je fais la game qui m'aurait permis d'atteindre le nirvana.
D'être plus excité qu'un ouistiti devant midi les zouzous. La onzième game.
ça s'est mal passé.
Je redescends à 2968 de cote.
Si je gagne cette deuxième partie.
Hors game de classement. Je passe Diamant.
C'est là qu'Overwatch m'a fait une Amy Whinehouse.
Il m'a regardé dans les yeux, et il m'a dit :
"I said, No, No, Noo"
Achète des skins, fils de pute !
Ma cote est descendu à 2948.
il me fallait maintenant deux victoires, deux victoires
pour pouvoir passer diamant
mais deux victoires dans une vie c'est quoi ?
c'est quoi après deux défaites ? Les probabilités sont que si tu perd deux fois tu va gagner deux fois
je perd la troisième game, je perd la quatrième game, je perd la cinquième game
je perd la sixième game, je perd la septième game, je perd la huitième game
je perd la neuvième game, je perd la dixième game, je perd la onzième game
JE PLEURE de toute mes forces
rien que d'en reparler ça me tend
tu vois j'ai envie de frapper un cadre, mais je ne le ferais parce que j'ai "DOFUS"
si jamais vous illustrer ça avec des figurines je vous dirais
ça c'est ma tête après les games de classement, après avoir fait 7 victoires sur 10 games et penser atterrir dans la catégorie diamant
ça c'est moi en voyant que j'ai atterri dans la catégorie platine avec une cote de 2988
et je suis passé un chouïa du diamant
et ça c'est moi après les putains de 11 défaites d'affilées mon pote
les amis je suis un gros haineux sur les jeux vidéos, mais surtout les jeux vidéos ou c'est en équipe
pas les jeux vidéos ou t'es seul par exemple hearthstone ou je sais pas starcraft mais si je n'y joue pas
tu es seul, tu peux compter que sur toi même si tu perd tu perd, c'est que tu es nul
je suis un putain de haineux sur les jeux vidéos et j'ai envie, j'ai envie qu'un traitement existe comme un patch à la nicotine
quand t'arrête fumer, un patch anti-rage sur les jeux vidéos pour juste s'amuser
se dire la défaite c'est quoi, c'est pas grave, on est la pour s'amuser, on n'est pas là pour gagner
mais qui a dit cette phrase un jour, c'est faux
la je vous avoue, c'est insupportable en 2016 les jeux euh euh comment te dire à plusieurs
parce que quand dans ton équipe quelque chose ne va pas et que tu dis à la personne bon t'es pas très fort avec ce perso
prend plutôt lui si tu es chaud avec se sera mieux et que le mec se braque et même t'insulte
mais WTF mais moi quand on me donne un conseil j'dis bah mec merci tu as raison
j'vais pas t'insulter et te dire " EH J'SUIS PLUS FORT QUE TOI ", c'est débile
et là on dirait une vieille merde qui fait une vidéo pour supporter le poids de onze défaites d'affilés
et c'est exactement le cas "rire" si la maintenant tout de suite je vous fait une game d'hearthstone
j'vais pas rager, parce que c'est un jeu en 1 contre 1, après c'est facile de mettre la faute sur les autres
De dire : "ah c'est mon équipe qui était nul c'est pas moi"
NON !!
moi je l'admets quand je suis une grosse merde et que je fais une game pourrie mais ça se voit
A la fin t'as pas de médaille d'or dans Overwatch pas de médaille pas de mérite pas de mérite pas de skill
j'aimerais aujourd'hui
qu'on fasse une sorte Genki dama
Que tout le monde lève les mains en l'air devant son PC
Et stop la-haut devant la maman qui passe derrière et teint le linge
Et envoyez-moi votre énergie
pour ne plus rager devant les jeux vidéos
J'la ressent . Ooh j'la ressent un peu trop
Ooh mon dieu . Aah c'est trop pour mon p'tit corps
aghr *explosion*
Si vous tombez avec moi dans une partie d'Overwatch mon pseudo est Squeezie
Mais plein d'gens peuvent avoir le même pseudo donc ça sera pas forcément moi
Bah même si c'est un autre quelqu'un qui n'a pas de vie
Qui veut m'copier, qui veut être nul comme moi sur Overwatch
Eh ben soyez doux et gentils avec nous prenez-le par la main
Et il vous prendra par le bras
Merci d'm'avoir écouter et n'oubliez pas
Vive la France
Vive la démocratie et vive la république. Merci !!
Non mais non mon équipe était nulle aussi la